nous sommes tous vos témoins
que du côté américain constamment
cette rhétorique ressemble à ceci
appelés prisonniers politiques dans
Russie, mais le sujet du vrac est généralement
discuté lors de vos négociations avec
Biden et comme discuté si
discuté et une autre question importante que nous
tout le monde a été témoin bien sûr de ce que nous disons
donc une nouvelle étape en russo-américain
relations au début de la présidence
canopée
a commencé par une déclaration très grossière
adresse ici à cette occasion en quelque sorte gérée
peut être expliqué
merci le président biden a abordé le sujet
droits de l'homme et les personnes qui considèrent
ce qu'ils représentent des questions dans
Fédération de Russie oui nous en avons parlé
ceci à son initiative
première seconde sur les déclarations dures
que dire de tout ce que nous savons ces derniers
déclaration après que le président Biden
J'ai appelé, nous avons expliqué le changement
explications arrangées qu'il nous a offertes
rencontrer le même son initiative
nous nous sommes rencontrés et je répète que la conversation était
très constructif encore une fois
convaincu que le président Biden
personne très expérimentée
évidemment nous sommes nez à nez avec lui
parler pendant presque deux heures pas avec tout le monde
les dirigeants donc c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans le détail
conversation face à face concernant
toutes sortes d'accusations mais rappelez-vous
son prédécesseur
on lui a posé la même question qu'il a évitée
Président actuel Président des États-Unis
J'ai décidé de répondre de cette façon, j'ai en quelque sorte
sa réponse était différente de celle de M.
atout, vous savez essentiellement tout ce qui
se passe dans nos pays d'une manière ou d'une autre
responsable de cela
dirigeants politiques et hauts fonctionnaires
sous à propos de qui et où
et quelle est la faute de qui regarde le tueur
ici dans les rues des villes américaines
chaque jour quelqu'un est tué, y compris
et et les dirigeants de diverses organisations là-bas
les mots n'ont pas le temps de dire déjà tirer
ou sa poitrine soit dans le dos à l'extérieur
dépend de lui à côté de vous les enfants
ou une personne juste ici dont je me souviens a jeté
femme a couru dans la voiture et à l'arrière
tire un coup veut dire ok c'est tout
choses criminelles que l'afghanistan prend là-bas
un coup à 120 chèques a tué des mariages
détruit 1 et 2 disons que c'est une erreur
cela arrive aussi, mais les fusillades avec
des drones ou des hélicoptères évidemment
les civils en irak sont clairement des civils
les personnes est ce qui est qui en est responsable
responsabilité
qui est le tueur ou les droits de l'homme
écoute moi mais guantanamo quand même
Ça ne foncrionne pas du tout
pas le droit international pas américain
il n'y a rien dans les lois mais existe toujours
cr prisons qui étaient ouvertes dans
différents pays, y compris européens
États
où la torture a été utilisée qu'est-ce que c'est
droit de l'homme ne pense pas vraiment à peine
si quelqu'un parmi ceux qui sont assis dans la salle est d'accord
qui protège ainsi les droits de l'homme revient au même
la pratique de la realpolitik et nous procédons
de cette pratique, comprendre ce que c'est
a été fait et peut être fait nous construisons
mon attitude vis-à-vis de ce dont je parle maintenant
vient de parler à ceux
les personnes qui reçoivent de l'argent de l'étranger
pour défendre les intérêts de ceux qui
paie